Hello.
This is Dr. Cutters.
What I answer a couple of questions that you sent in.
Here's some questions about the ion pro-way.
The foot bath was only dirty the first time.
What does it mean if it's clear?
Well, if your foot bath is perfectly clear like this picture after you run the program,
I would question something wrong with the foot bath, something wrong with your connection.
Do you have it flipped on to bath instead of bulb?
Are you ready?
And pro-way program is not running a bulb program, or have you outused the foot bath,
meaning the foot bath itself is only going to work for about 80 to 100 sessions, and then
it burns out to you, do you replace your foot bath?
Or is there something wrong with the connection?
Is there something wrong with the connection inside the right direction, or is there something
wrong with the connection with the foot bath down at the plate inside that little
plastic thing in the foot bath?
So it shouldn't be perfectly clear like that, even if you're perfectly healthy, it'll never
be perfectly clear.
But no, it's not perfectly clear, it's just a little bit problem.
Well, that can be normal.
So if it is changing some colors that we know it's working, and please don't be hung up on
the color.
I am not, and you've heard me say this multiple times, I do not believe that the colors mean certain
things.
So one-to-one correlation by any stretch of the imagination that water is slightly green,
so I must be pulling stuff from my gallbladder, or it's yellow, I might be pulling stuff
from my kidney or something, that just does not make sense.
So please don't follow that.
It's different colors because of the different frequencies it's running.
So don't be googly color charts for ion pro wave things, I don't care who they're from.
I just don't, that's just my opinion, so do what you want to do.
So can the foot baths cause nausea?
A second part of this question, well, I've not heard that.
I suppose anything could, if you're running frequencies detoxification program on the foot
bath or something like that, it certainly could be affected your gallbladder, could be
affected your kidney area, yes, your kidney, or your liver, and I guess it could cause nausea.
I mean, there's always that possibility, I've heard that comment, but yeah, you should maybe
talk to me about that if that's caused, if that's happening all the time.
And is there a certain number of hours between the daily foot baths?
I have said over and over that I think maybe doing one foot bath a day is really the maximum.
I know there's some people that do more, there's some people that don't do it at all.
I kind of fall on that side of the spectrum, but I typically recommend a couple of times
a week, if you really love doing the foot bath that makes you feel better doing it once
a day seems reasonable, doing it more than that might be too much.
So, but there's not a certain number of hours.
So if you do it tonight and then I do it tomorrow morning because that's just what my schedule
is like, that's no harm, then you wait till the next morning to do the next one, that's
the, it's not a specific time, it's just doing maybe too many in any given week.
So make sure you send in your questions that you have, I'll try to make little videos about
this if we don't get them on the Zoom call.
Alright, thanks so much.